i actually
we i filmed a video with him so we did
the subscriber counter
which i don't think has been published
anywhere i'm not i'm not making a video
but i'm not doing another project for
him like i was just like nope just gonna
do this thing yeah i'm not gonna
document it yeah um
but i asked him if i could like make a
video i lived with him for 24 hours
and he said yes oh wow oh okay so i got
to spend a full 24 hours like going
through exactly what they do every
single day right and got to sleep in his
uh
it was his bedroom
uh
and it's definitely like there's a lot
of like chaperoning where it's like you
gotta be here you gotta be here like his
phone's always going off like people are
always like asking him for feedback
about stuff and it's like it's a lot
like i definitely
you know it's a it's a whole thing you
get anxiety just being near it yeah kind
of i think at the end of the day i would
not trade places with him no no way no
way like absolutely not i don't so what
did you do in this one 24 hours then
just everything you did when when is it
coming out the video i i don't know or
something i noticed that when i start to
you're like yeah editing it takes a
while
yeah because you still do your editing
right and everything yeah we've been
i've been
having somebody help me which has been
helping a lot um like i think that i
just
i don't know i mean i don't know how you
guys edit but like for me it's like i
try to like figure out like the best way
to make it work yeah i mean they don't
edit it
i i give like i used to and then i found
why would i why did i i did the opposite
yeah i used to not
oh she because i was like i am a bad
editor yeah and there are people who are
very good at it i'm a bad editor i
should just get back
until it makes sense
yeah i mean i still edit everything i do
and it's more of just i think i've just
realized that 90 of this work was like
there there are some things i really
value in terms of my editing in terms of
like how it portrays my personality and
everything like that and i realized that
was only about ten percent of the video
maybe so i can get someone else to do
the stuff that i hated doing which is
just cutting down this timeline and
getting this uh getting this into the
timeline and finding the presentation
yeah and then i could do the fun parts
yeah so sorry alan
that's what i'm trying to do but like
one of the things we've been thinking
about a lot recently is is like why are
people watching certain things like what
is it about a video that gets people
like why do people spend time watching
you do it yeah you know so it's like
trying to right here just to suffer well
boy you know so it's like you know i
never really understood twitch for the
longest time
and then i realized like oh my god i
drive to school every single day
listening to like a radio talk show yeah
that's exactly the same thing like
literally exactly the same thing yeah
yeah and so now you can just see the
face right yeah and
i think that
when i like try to think of why i watch
videos like i like stories i like sort
of interesting you know facts i like
like like motivation and purpose
and so i've been trying to like figure
out how do you become like how do you
make the audience understand that
motivation and purpose before getting
into a video like why are you doing what
you're doing you know yeah why should
they stay to the end
yeah how do you get like what's your
creative process in terms of like making
ideas then because it feels like your
videos now are so varied in terms of
ideas is there like you you just like
come up with a random idea was it like
an entire process to be like this would
be an interesting story to tell so
sometimes it's
this would be an interesting title
thumbnail like i think this title
thumbnail would work well is that
something mark robert taught me a long
time ago of like if i can't imagine the
title thumbnail i won't film the video
we've said this as well yeah and that's
can be really frustrating
as i guess like the artist side of
things of like but i want to do this
thing but i don't have ideas how do you
tell people how do you convince people
to watch a thing you know and they'll
you know everyone will tell you like oh
that sounds interesting and it's like
it's easy to say but actually you know
clicking on is a different story yeah
and so that's that's something where you
know i'm like what what tends to work
well this is if anybody's trying to do
youtube is what is an actual problem you
actually have that you can fix
yeah that works really well like here is
an issue in my life that will most
likely relate to other people yeah yeah
and that's going to do two things like
it's going to help establish why you're
doing it and it's going to tell them why
they should get to the end of it yeah do
you need to go to the doctor for your ct
scan are you putting it off
i actually spent days like i was
planning on doing an x-ray video before
i went to the hospital right that that
video scared a lot of people there right
yeah because they were like
x-ray yeah it's i mean it's not good but
it's not that bad
okay hold on hold on break that down
right what do you mean
i'm not i'm not a radiation expert at
all
so i think i'm the right guy for the job
x-rays are ionizing radiation which
means that they can damage your cells
which can cause cancer so statistically
speaking if you're exposed to more
ionizing radiation you will have a
higher chance of getting cancer yeah if
you get on an airplane you're being
exposed to ionizing radiation if you
work on an airplane you are regularly
being exposed to ionizing radiation an
x-ray is pretty much in the same
ballpark as taking flights
so if you work as like a stewardess or a
pilot you are being exposed to way way
way way more radiation than whatever
that video was i know that yeah which is
a little terrifying we've gone on a lot
of flights
oh yeah of course i took my geyer
counter on a flight because i wanted to
like no i i was like panicking i had to
shut it up because it was
like beeping
yes it was going ape [ __ ] and i was like
it sounded like a bomb was going off and
i was like trying to figure out how to
mute it really quick oh my god i'm like
sitting on my seat and everyone around
me
it's that bad yeah
sometimes there's some knowledge that
you don't need to know i think that was
like one of it you know all right i
found a chart radiation dose chart so uh
sleeping next to someone this is from
xkcd sleeping next to somebody is .05
micro sieverts okay which is nothing uh
background dose receives
background radiation dose received by an
average person over one normal day is 10
micro sieverts okay a flight from new
york to la's 40 micro sieverts okay
just existing
you get background radiation a dental
x-ray is five micro sieverts
well less than the average day that you
get yes
oh and the plane is 40 40. so it's like
getting five of those i suppose yeah huh
so then a chest x-ray is 20 micro
sieverts mm-hmm so it's half a plane
yeah
okay so if you sit on a plane from la to
new york that is you're getting two
extras you're getting two chest x-rays
okay what's what's what's up on that
list uh by the end of the trash taste
tour we're gonna be like glowing
connor's gonna have like a third arm
yeah
the epa's yearly release target for a
nuclear power plant 30 micro sieverts
well just being working at the place so
i think it's i think so yes i think it
sounds like it's very strict basically
you can't have any radiation leaking
from a power plant that'd be 30 a day um
yearly oh it may be released i'm not
really sure exactly what 30 yearly
uh no every every year 30 micro secrets
jesus
um it just gets worse and worse too when
you get because it all depends i think
on like where the x-rays are going
because yeah yeah the head can be really
bad and whatnot but long story short uh
it's it's not that bad i think eating
one banana is 1.1 micro sievert so yeah
if you ate 50 bananas that's one dental
x-ray i mean yeah [ __ ] that's fine
that's what i my daily diet yeah i'm
taking advantage of every day i should
x-ray myself yeah so x-raying your hand
wasn't that dangerous but a few people
were freaking out remember
what the [ __ ] yeah and i talked to some
uh someone i went to high school with is
a like basically like a radiation kind
of engineer for medical equipment and
she basically said like it's
it's not a big deal
i'll text myself
right now good
yeah
but disclaimer it is not good
please don't do it at home please don't
go out and go buying x-rays it's like
drinking alcohol like would you ever
tell somebody that drinking alcohol was
healthy no no no
well well alcohol was like you know
people that's i think i think it's
because it's like you can't see it yeah
it's scary i don't know what's happening
like media too has built it up it's not
like this
crazy cancer it comes from space yeah
yeah i mean that that led into the video
about you getting like hate comments as
well which i thought was amazing yeah
and a lot of people got mad at that one
of course they're gonna get [ __ ] mad
i think about everything even like
friends i know who don't watch your
channel yeah they they who are youtubers
have watched that video yeah because
it's i think this is something that a
lot of people in the industry or field
can relate to a lot if you've ever seen
this video no i've seen it yeah okay
well it's uh explain explain the video
so i'm very much a noob when it comes to
your channel that's fine it's fine uh i
had
done a video in the past where i like
like kind of looked at hate comments or
writing comments where it was like i
think buying when i bought it i bought a
battle bot
and some people i knew it was gonna
drive some people nuts and so i took
some of those comments and kind of made
a humorous video around it and i'm like
oh i did the x-ray video and got the
same thing i was like i'll do the same
thing yeah uh but i
uh
someone was pretending to be an expert
yeah and so i basically reached out to
them
and i
kind of
made them
talk in a way that revealed they were
not really that much of an expert
because i've had a lot of interactions
online related to like engineering and
safety which are kind of frustrating
because like someone said stuff is like
not super safe
but not crazy dangerous like i'm
probably a lot safer than most people
think uh like i remember long ago i made
a video where i was testing safety
glasses with my laser cutter
and there was a comment talking about
not having to wear safety glasses around
laser cutter he works with but like what
the guy was completely missing was that
the laser cutter i had uses like a
mid-range infrared light yeah and the
laser cutter he was using is like a near
ir so like near ir will go right through
your cornea
whereas the mid-range will like
basically stop at your cornea i mean
it'll still burn the crap out of your
eye but yeah and so you end up with like
people are very willing to communicate
completely like wrong information which
is terrifying in a confident time yes
exactly it's like you know you're
talking about something that could like
blind people yeah and it's like no you
don't need to do that i don't wear dude
i don't do this and it's like oh my god
and i remember like you know replying to
him i don't really i don't reply to
comments anyways it was years ago and i
said like are you talking about like
fiber lasers like this is really
different bubble and it's like oh yeah i
didn't i guess i guess that that's not
and it's like if somebody read this
they're gonna i was like oh okay i guess
i don't need to yeah yeah exactly so i
get really frustrated sometimes seeing
like the kind of like the technical
talking people just say you think i mean
that's what i do on the podcast i just
say [ __ ] that i'm i'm confident about
that is completely wrong right
let's just
do that all three of us do of course
yeah and we've done that plenty of times
i'm like i'm incredibly paranoid about
doing that i don't know why other than
like for safety stuff explicitly like i
do not understand a lot more with when
you're making stuff and safety stuff
that you would take that a lot more
seriously yeah
you if you say the wrong thing about an
anime series it's not a life or death
yeah so
our audience knows not to listen to our
[ __ ] clowns to begin with anyway but
i guess i guess with you all expertise
and how
how your content is like
right what your content is about i can
see why people would
i guess pay more attention to that right
yeah there's a bit more severity to you
know saying the wrong thing i feel so i
try to put disclaimers where it's like
i'm not an expert or i think this is how
it works yeah
that way it's kind of like here i'm
gonna fuzz it a little bit this is what
i'm pretty sure how it works but also
you know don't quote me on that i've
been on the internet for a couple hours
researching it and i think you know like
for the ct scanner i think i've watched
maybe like four hours of college
lectures about ct scanning and like
computer topography and it's like does
that make me an expert no but i also
wrote a python script that does you know
ct math so it's like
where do i fall i don't know well i've
always actually wondered actually
because talking talking to you and
talking to a lot of people on safety
third and a lot of people involved in
this side of youtube it seems like you
guys
are
more than anyone else on youtube willing
to risk safety to make good content yeah
what is your line because we had nigel
on last week and and that was just kind
of like he has no idea that that was
just like interviewing a serial arsenal
yeah